può la bellezza
la domanda
riess chi mette in bocca a di police
nell'idiota per me in realtà la domanda
alla domanda cui cercherò di rispondere
nei prossimi minuti e può alla
produzione di beni e servizi di alta
gamma salvare o contribuire a migliorare
l'economia europea ea quella italiana
e parlando di produzione di beni e
servizi evidentemente parliamo di
progettazione di manifattura e siamo al
cuore dell'industria questa mattina
picchetti ed altri economisti hanno
ripreso alcuni piccoli elementi di un
dibattito che 30 anni fa era molto forte
e che riguardava la contrapposizione tra
il capitalismo renano quello che sulle
due sponde del reno si era sviluppato
tra dalla metà dell'ottocento in poi e
di cui balzac da un lato e thomas mann
in particolare nei buden brocca avevano
dato una straordinaria rappresentazione
letteraria il capitalismo renano da una
parte il capitalismo anglosassone
dall'altra un elemento comune essendo
sistemi economici essendo sistemi
economici sostanzialmente coesi dovevano
rispondere ovviamente al mercato ma con
una differenza perché per quanto
riguarda il capitalismo renano che
doveva rispondere anche alla società e
perciò doveva rispondere ad una funzione
che era quella di creare ricchezza per
la società il territorio le persone le
famiglie dei luoghi in cui queste
imprese si erano sviluppate mentre il
capitalismo anglosassone ha avuto una
natura differente quella di rispondere
solo al mercato e perciò sostanzialmente
di produrre ricchezza
per qualcuno non tanti relativamente
pochi e molto spesso molto lontani
geograficamente in paesi dove si pagano
meno tasse o dove non si pagano del
tutto dove ci sono le coperture eccetera
eccetera eccetera
questo dibattito è diventato rapidamente
obsoleto perché come è noto il
capitalismo anglosassone ha stravinto il
capitalismo anglosassone non solo ha
stravinto a causa delle due economie o
per il ruolo politico degli stati uniti
in primis e del regno unito che l'hanno
seguito ma perché i cinesi hanno deciso
di seguire quel modello e così gli
indiani e così il latino americani
eccetera eccetera
poi sappiamo anche come è andata a
finire nel 2008 2009 in cui è stata
creata questa sfida questa questa crisi
finanziaria globale proprio da questo
tipo di modello e io continuo a ritenere
che la ragione sono tra quelli che che
sostengono che il fatto che si tratti di
fenomeni globali e invece i sistemi di
controllo delle attività economiche sono
solo nazionali
evidentemente ha lasciato la porta
aperta ai buoi
ma sarà sempre così perché purtroppo i
due g20 dell'anno 2009 che dovevano
avevano come obiettivo quello di
definire dei sistemi di sorveglianza
sovranazionali come probabilmente
ricordate sono andati completamente
falliti e qui siamo in europa e in
italia ma in europa soprattutto abbiamo
tre anime c'è un'anima finanziaria che
riguarda le banche che riguarda i fondi
di investimento che riguarda le
assicurazioni c'è un'anima dei servizi
che riguarda il trading all'ingrosso a
del taglio di prodotti manufatti
normalmente in paesi dove il costo del
lavoro il più basso in assoluto per cui
attualmente l'asia in futuro l'africa
e poi c'è l'anima della manifattura
io credo che la ragione per cui la
germania è tra i paesi occidentali
quello dinamicamente industrialmente più
strutturato ed efficace e proprio perché
è riuscito in qualche modo a integrare
lo spirito del
del capitalismo anglosassone con quello
del capitalismo renano è però anche per
l'europa si pone nel commercio
internazionale quello di trovare il modo
di competere sempre di più nell'economia
del valore invece che nella competizione
di prezzo ma la germania un passo molto
avanti l'ha fatto molto più del nostro
paese invece in cui ci sono larghi
strati della produzione industriale
soprattutto a livello piccolo medio che
ancora cercano impropriamente di
competere nella produzione nella
competizione di prezzo e io credo invece
che una la legge della divisione della
nazionale del lavoro richieda che
rapidamente l'italia faccia un upgrading
di posizionamento verso la produzione la
competizione di valore e veniamo così ai
beni di cui mi occupo solo per ricordare
che una volta soddisfatti i bisogni
primari gli individui normalmente
svolgono alla loro soddisfazione ad ai
beni simbolici e negli ultimi secoli
label sacralizzazione ha investito quasi
tutte le sfere della dell'esistenza
dell'esperienza umana ma il bisogno di
simboli non è sparito anzi mi pare che
si sia sempre più spostato nella
dimensione materiale in cui gli
individui cercano di inquisiti
contemporanei cercano di dare o di
costruire un loro orizzonte di senso
attraverso queste due poli
ontologicamente contrapposti tra due
esigenze contrapposte di appartenenza e
di differenziazione i prodotti e servizi
di alta gamma sono patrimonio d'europa e
d'italia e vediamone rapidamente gli
aspetti quantitativi il mondo
parliamo di consumi mondiali è un
mercato in grandissima crescita nel 2014
un anno fa erano 390 milioni i
consumatori che hanno acquistato
prodotti e servizi
di alta gamma e o di lusso erano 140
milioni nell'anno 2000 si è parlato
largamente oggi dell'uno per cento della
popolazione che si contrappone al 99 beh
possiamo dire che almeno a questo
livello che la democrazia più ampia
siamo al 5,3 cento rispetto all'uno per
cento hanno acquistato questi 390
milioni di persone per 750 5 miliardi di
euro per cui soltanto se consideriamo
beni e servizi ma escludendo le
automobili e la nautica perché questi da
soli in aggiunta hanno rappresentato 350
miliardi di euro di consumi nel 2021
questi 390 milioni di consumatori
saranno almeno 465 milioni
ho dato la stima più pessimistica perché
la stima più ottimistica e che saranno
attorno ai 550 e spenderanno almeno un
trilione e qualche cosa di euro
sempre senza considerare le automobili
la nautica
veniamo all'europa l'europa dicevo
domina questo mercato domina in primo
luogo con una quota del 70 per cento il
70 per cento di quello che consuma
mentre si consuma nel mondo da parte dei
consumatori più sofisticati abbienti
appartiene ad imprese ea marche europee
e sono 547 miliardi di euro nel 2013 il
4 per cento del pil europeo
questo settore tra il 2013 e il 2010 in
tre anni che non sono stati propriamente
più facile dell'economia europea e
mondiale è aumentato del 28 per cento e
gli occupati sono passati da un milione
e mezzo in europa un milione e 700 mila
700 milioni con un aumento di 200 mila
unità
non c'è nessun altro settore economico
europeo che abbia avuto una performance
e le esportazioni fuori europa senza
considerare quello che l'italia esporta
in francia in germania o quello che la
germania o la francia esportano gli
altri paesi dell'unione europea
quello che è andato proprio fuori dai 28
paesi sarei stato pari a 308 miliardi di
euro che rappresentano il 17 per cento
di tutte le esportazioni di merci
europee il che vuol dire che ogni 10
euro esportate dall'europa ormai 1,7
speriamo rapidamente potremmo arrivare a
due sono prodotti di alta gamma
l'italia l'italia nel 1000 2013 le
imprese in italia le imprese di di alta
gamma hanno una quota del 15 per cento
del mercato mondiale perché
rappresentiamo l'uno per cento della
popolazione mondiale abbiamo in questo
settore 15 per cento di quota dei
consumi nei pressi degli anni hanno
esportato 50 per cento in europa e fuori
dell'europa tra il 2013 e il 2010
l'aumento del fatturato è stato del 23
per cento
l'occupazione è aumentata del 10 per
cento tra il 2010 e il 2013 e siamo
adesso a 550mila persone che sono
impiegate da questa industria nel nostro
paese è questo un punto molto importante
che le imprese italiane di alta gamma
sono le locomotive di tutte le filiere
in cui operano le imprese di alta gamma
dell'illuminazione e dell'arredamento lo
sono per tutte le altre che sono nella
media e anche in qualche caso nella
malga ma medio bassa lo sono il settore
dei vini o nel settore alimentare lo
sono nel settore della moda lo sono nei
settori della tecnologia e queste
scegliere tutte insieme rappresentano il
25 per cento del pil del nostro paese ed
è un caso una sì che i colleghi
economisti presenti in sala che hanno
parlato prima o dopo
non conoscono bene la competitività
delle filiere italiane a livello
internazionale è sempre maggiore quando
ci sono dei campioni delle imprese
leader note italiane note a livello
internazionale
e queste filiere rappresentano tutte
insieme il 27 per cento delle
esportazioni italiane il 40 per cento
delle vendite di prodotti di alta gamma
e fatta turisti stranieri
il 35 per cento dei turisti stranieri
extra europei che vengono in europa
affermano divenire per comprare prodotti
di qualità e d'immagine superiore
le imprese italiane di alta gamma hanno
contribuito e contribuiscono a rendere
belli vivibili e sicure anche di sera i
centri storici delle nostre città e
contribuiscono alla valorizzazione del
patrimonio culturale italiano dai
restauri della della fontana di trevi a
quella della barcaccia an rapidamente
rovinata dopo l'ultimo restauro a quello
del colosseo sostengono l'arte
contemporanea
la fondazione prada è uno degli ultimi
esempi in questo senso
queste imprese promuovono nel mondo
un'immagine dell'italia molto positiva
una immagine che è fatta di cultura
materiale che è fatta di stile di vita
di creatività ed innovazione
torniamo alla domanda di politica e io
credo che la risposta possa essere solo
positiva se l'italia intera condivide un
disegno strategico comune per competere
nella competizione di valore allora
probabilmente alcune quelle adesso non
si parla più di politica industriale a
bruxelles hanno inventato il termine
smart spese a live nation
io credo che per l'europa per i tagli in
particolare il fatto di produrre dei
prodotti di qualità superiori ad alto
contenuto di innovazione ad alto
contenuto estetico ad alto contenuto
simbolico sia oggettivamente
assolutamente no
tre corde e credo che in questo modo
potremmo continuare a soddisfare i
consumatori sofisticati di tutto il
mondo nella loro ricerca di avere
bisogno di soddisfare i loro business
simbolici
grazie
[Applauso]